[موسيقى]
نختلف دائما في اسره البرنامج على جواب
لسؤال مركب هل علينا ان نفرض مساحه للصغار
المتطاولين على الكبار الذين رحلوا عن هذه
الدنيا وتركوا فيها اثار علميه وفكريه
ظاهره لنسلم بذلك في شهرت هؤلاء الصغار
المتفلسفين بلا فلسفه جوهريه
والمتسلقين بدون حبال علم ومعرفه ام
نتخطاهم وكانهم لم يكونوا
غالبا ما يستقر الرايه على تخصيص مساحه
صغيره لذلك فلا يليق في زمن تخزين الصوت
والصوره ان نترك المنصات تنتفخ بمعاور
الجهل تنبش قبور الصالحين
اما عن الاسامي في شهره هؤلاء المتسلقين
فان ابا لها بنت تبت يداه اكثر منهم شهره
ولم يغني عنه ماله وما كسب الى العناوين
هجمه شرسه على الشعراوي ترعاها وزيره
الثقافه والازهر ومستشار السيسي يردان
العراق يظهر العرب في افتتاح كاس الخليج
بعد ما انتهى من خصومه قيس سعيد يبدا
باقاله انصاره
فضيحه ثانيه لبرنامج امير الشعراء حكام لا
يجيدون القراءه
جيشم ينمار الحاكم يكرم بن لادن البوذي
بتوصيف مجله التايم
السويد تقفل مدارس المسلمين وطالبان تقفل
جامعات طالباتهم
مشهد انصار ترامب في الكونجرس يتكرر بنسخه
برازيليه
[موسيقى]
انا لله وانا اليه راجعون في الجنيه
المصري
اللهم احشرهم على الدينار الكويتي
والدولار اللهم اسكنه فسيح البنوك اللهم
امين ومن الفزع البنك الدولي وصندوق النقد
الدولي يلا
مرحبا انه مسن مصري يدعو على طريقته
للجنيه فيثير جدلا بسبب استخدامه خاصيه
الدعاء للسخريه من هبوط العمله المحليه
التي كاد ان يقيم عليها طقوس تكريم الموتى
اصوات اخرى في مصر لم تحركها التحديات
حياه المصريين فذهبت الى مقابرهم تنبشها
محاوله تلطيخه اكفاني الصالحين بخلوف
السنه
والمصريون يجمعون اليوم على نبذ الفتن
واهلها وعلى التضامن وعدم التنافر كالماء
والزيت في وقت ينفذ فيه الزيت من بعض
المتاجر المعروفه الكبرى امام الدعاه كما
يوصف وزير الاوقاف المصري الاسبق العلامه
الراحل محمد متولي عرابي تتطاول على فكره
مجموعه كاطفال ارادوا اتلاف نخله عاليه
فسقطت احجارهم فوق رؤوسهم وظلت الثمار
خالصه للمتذوقين تعجب الناظرين يعلق الشيخ
عباس شومان الوكيل السابق للازهر ومن
الازهر بيان يشيد بالامام الشعراوي الذي
وهب حياته لتفسير كتاب الله واوقف عمره
لتلك المهمه حمله التجريح بالشعراوي التي
قادتها اصابع حكوميه رد عليها المستشار
الديني لرئيس الجمهوريه الشيخ اسامه
الازهري بان الشعراوي هو من حمى المصريين
من التطرف الشيخ الشعراوي كان حائط الصد
الذي يحمل مصريين من فكره التطرف
اعاده جمع شمل المصريين على تذوق القران
الكريم وان مفتاح القران الكريم هو مش ادي
الجمال وهو مش قد الفهم ومشهد النورانيه
وليس مشهد التكفير والجاهليه نحن في فتره
السبعينات كنا نعاني من هذه الهجمه
الشديده الشراسه وفي ظل هذا برز صوت عاقل
حكيم اعجب به المصريون كان هو صوت الشيخ
الشعراوي الامام الشعراوي ليس معصوما ابدا
ونتاجه الفكري الشخصي قابل للكثير من
النقد والمراجعه لكن مما من اهل العلم
والاختصار كيف يعني يعني انا مثلا احب
مشاهده رقص الباليه وقراءه اللوحات
التعبيريه التي ترسمها الراقصه بجسدها لو
اردت اجراء تقييم لاداء راقصه على المسرح
لن اسمح لنفسيه بكتابه كلمه نقد واحده بل
سالوا الى المتخصصين الى الراقصه المصريه
بين الكيلاني مثلا فهي محترفه وذات باع
طويل
نيفين الراقصه المخرمه صارت وزيره الثقافه
فارادت من خارج اختصاصها توزيعه شهادات
التطرف والجهل والارهاب على الاموات
والاحياء
وخلصت الى حضر عمل مسرحيه عن الداعيه
الشعراوي فما علاقته مواهب نيفين بعلوم
الفقه والدين
الحقيقه احنا عايزين نعرف حقيقه وجود عمل
فني على المسرح القومي هيقدم في شهر رمضان
عن الشيخ محمد متولي الشعراوي ده حقيقي يا
فندم لا يا فندم مش
حقيقه
المجالات الثقافيه والفنيه والاجتماعيه
ولازم الاسم اللي يطرح اي يكون له اثر
ايجابي على المجتمع علشان
نغير الاف الاعلاميه ونكافح الفكر المتطرف
الوزيره الراقصه نيفين تسفه الامام
الشعراوي وتمجد حسين فهمي لفهم الصوره
يعني
الحقيقه يعني نموذج للفنان المصري الوطني
المثقف الواعي وانا بشكره للمره المليون
كنا لا نودوا فتحه الموضوع من اساسه لولا
ان الجدل لم يتوقف ابراهيم عيسى الذي يقدس
البقره ويعشق انوثتها كما قال سابقا يصف
الامام الشعراوي
بالداعشي والقاتل راي همم
الشعراوي الحقيقي هو رايي داعش ما تقوليش
وسطي ما تنطقهاش بلسانك
ده داعش
داعش بقى ولابسه عمه وقفطان وعامل كده
وبيكلم حلو وانت بتحبه دي مشكلتك البقره
مهم قوي انك تقعد تتامل البقره
وما فيش مشكله خالص انك انت تصدق ان شوكت
بالقدسها لانها تستاهل رجل يعرف عنه بانه
كاتب ومترجم لكنه يدعو الى المثليه
الدينيه وما هي المثليه الدينيه هي
الادعاء بعدم تعرض اعتقاض مع اعتقاض منافل
له نحن الان في بدايات التنوير لانه
التنوير الديني قصه كبيره قصه ضخمه جدا
تعني غرب كله من اوله لاخره مثلا كنيسه
المسيحي كانت كل الاديان الاخرى
بما فيها كانت تكافل الاسلام تكفل بوجهين
بل وداخل مسيحي كانت تكفل بالصوتين
عمرو ديب لم يركز على الجدل الديني فكان
منشغلا بالاعلان عن قرب بيع اصول الدوله
وكانه في حفله مزاد علني يعلق مراقب مالي
مرونه الجنيه او مرور الصرف هي اللي هتخلي
ناس تخش تشتري من عندك اصول ففضل اللي
جايه دي تسمع بقى في ناس جايه تشتري احمد
موسى كان الافضل بينهم هذا الاسبوع فانت
جليسه شخصيه جديده خبير تغذيه في ظل
الازمه المعيشيه في البلاد كل اسره تحط
اولوياتها السكر الابيض بالنسبه لي دلوقت
بقى ايه حاجه يعني ايضا القمح عيش القمح
يعني ايضا الرز خلاص
مكرونه اثنين صحتك تبقى كويسه جسمك يبقى
كويس
خالد الجندي يعتبره ان الشكوى من سوء
الاوضاع المعيشيه هي تشهير بالله سبحانه
وتعالى قدامك شكوى وقدامك شكر الاثنين
بيبداوا بحرف الشين شكوى ولا شكر نشوف
الشكوى بتعمل ايه الشكوى هذه بتتسبب في
غضب الله عز وجل لانك تقوم بالتشهير بالله
عز وجل هل انت تعيش في بلد يشتري سكانه
بطيخه كامله احترس فقد يغضب منك امين عام
الغرف التجاريه في مصر
عندنا ثقافه دي شكرا دكتور علاء عز امين
عامل غرف التجاريه على تليفون حضرتك في
مصر لا احد يشتري بطيخه على الاقل بطيخ
كانت ليه ثاني لان من يشتري ربع بطيخه
بيكون عايش لوحده مش مع اولاده ومراته
وامه وامه سبع اولاد
موجوده اه قاعده معايا
حماتك موجوده اهي في نفس الاوضه فين في
نفس الاوضه واحده
[موسيقى]
اعلن وعلى بركه الله
انطلاقا خليجي 25
جاء وسط اجواء من التفاؤل بتحقيق نجاح
تنظيمين كبير يليق بمكانه البطوله لدى
شعوب المنطقه والعالم افتتاح بطوله كاس
الخليج لكره القدم 25 في العراق كان مبهرا
لكنه لم يكن اكثر ابهان من كرم الشعب
العراقي
ايش هذا الكرم عشان
تفاجئنا
قهوتنا
يا اهل البصره احرقتونا والله اهل العراق
كلهم
اهل البصره او
اهلا في سياره قطريه يعني تبعد ضيوف وليست
عراقيين شوفوا شلون العراقيين بالشوارع
شلون راح يستقبلونه انا والاخ هذا من قطر
توكلنا على الله
ايران تعترض على اطلاق العراق صفه العرب
على الخليج فهو فارسي تقول
كاس الخليج العربي في البطوله الحاليه
واوضح البيان بحصوه الصحيفه ان خديجه
الفارسي هو اسم تاريخي وينطبق على كافه
اللغات والخرائط بين الجزائر وفرنسا ذاكره
سيئه جدا كما تعلمون لكن في النهايه لابد
من تنقيتها ولهذا الغرض اسست مجموعه
الصداقه الفرنسيه الجزائريه فرنسا عينت
نائبا لرئيس هذه المجموعه رجلا معاديا
للجزائر المستقل لو استحبتكم معي الى
الجزائر بما انني قد ذهبت الى هناك عده
مرات وتحديدا الى منطقه جبل طفراوي سوف
ترون العديد من الجزائريين الذين لا
يعرفون فرنسا لكنهم سيسالون قام متى تكون
مره اخرى هل ارتكبت فرنسا جرائم في
الجزائر
يا له من سؤال لا اعتقد ان ارتكب الجرائم
في الجزائر ولا اظن ان الجيش الفرنسي قد
يفعل ذلك ربما تجب مراجعه التاريخ لكنني
لا اعتقد ذلك يبدو ان الرئيس التونسي قيس
سعيد الذي قال معظم الدوله قد تعود على
الاقالات فبدا بدوره جديده تشمل من عينهم
بنفسه بعد حفله اقالات خصومه اقل رئيسه
التونسي قيس سعيد وزيره التجاره وتنميه
الصادرات فضيله الرابح وهي اول عضو في
حكومه نجلاء بودا يقيلها رئيس البلاد كذلك
قرر سعيد انهاء مهام ولي مدينه صفاقس ثاني
مدن البلاد فاخر الفخفاخ الذي عينه الماضي
ولم تعطي رئاسه اسبابا محدده للاقالتين
تاتيان وسط ازمه الاقتصاديه والقسمه
سياسيه في فيلم روك يستعيد الجيش الامريكي
بسجين خطير للمساعده على انهاء تمرد فرقه
من الجيش كمترست داخل سجن بحري معقد
الجنرال السوداني حمدي المتهم بالانقلاب
على عمر البشير يعلن انه احبط محاوله
انقلاب في افريقيا الوسطى كانت تحضر
انطلاقا من الاراضي السودان لكن لمن تساوي
المصيبه
النهائيه والحدود الان قفل
ناه ثابته طوالي يعني ما في بيننا
الدخلاويه
معقول الرجال تحكيم عفوا بس انه معقول
اليسا عم بتصلح صوت لوحده بتغني عشر مرات
احسن منها الموسيقار زياد الرحباني
فضيحه ثانيه خلال اسبوع واحد
في الاورده في التراكيب الشعريه ان يكتزك
الطريق
ويطفي شاعريه خاصه
وكلها وكلها معاني مكونه الشاعر
[موسيقى]
اريد التوضيح باسم الشعب اليهودي في
العالم كله بان الدين اليهودي يرفض بشكل
مطلق الدخول الى حرم المسجد الاقصى نريد
ان نوضح للمسلمين ان ما اقدم عليه من غفير
يتعارض مع الدين اليهودي ولا يعبر عنا بل
يسيئوا الى اليهود هذا الموقف لزعيم حركه
لاطوري كارتا اليهودي غير الصهيونيه قد
يعرضه للخطر عند المتطرفين الذين لا يضيق
صدرهم بالمسلمين والمسيحيين فقط بل ايضا
بكل يهودي يرفض التعدي على مقدسات الاخرين
كنائس القدس الشرقيه ومقابر المسيحيين
فيها مسرح دائم لعبث المتطرفين الشهيدات
المقبره البرتقانديه على اطراف البلده
القديمه بالقدس الشرقيه تقريبا لعشرات
القبور وانتهاك لحرمتها من الصلباني
والشواهد التي تميزها لقطات كاميرا امنيه
تعود الى الاول من يناير تظهر الشابين
يرتديان زيا اليهود المتدينين يخربان
الموقع بعد اخبار هل ادي صعب يتلقيناها
بتكسير شواهد القبور بتكسير السلطان وهذا
عمل مش بس جبان هو عمل مقزز عمل اللي
بيرفضوا اي انسان فيه قطر الدم انسانيه
الراهب البوذي وراثه عام 2013 اطلقت عليه
مجله التعليم لقب بن لادن البوذي وصنف
بانه راس التطرف الديني البوذي البرمي ضد
المسلمين
ولاسيما اقليه الرهينجا
التي ساهم في مجازر الاباده و جرائم
التهجير بحقها
بتهمه اثاره الفتن سجدته حكومه
الان لدى المجلس العسكري الحاكم الذي لم
يكتفي باطلاق راس الارهاب البوداوي من
السجن عام 2021
واسقاطي تهم الارهاب عنه بلكرمه هذا
الاسبوع ومنحه جائزه وطنيه رفيعه يحرص
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على اظهار
التزامه بتعاليم الكنيسه وطقوسها ولا يفوت
عيدا دون ان يذهب فيه الى الكنيسه ويشارك
في القداس
ولمناسبه عيد الميلاد بالتقويم الارثوذكسى
الروسي اعلن بوتين عن هدنه مطلع الاسبوع
رفضتها قياده اوكرانيا فرد عليها نائب
الرئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ديمترمات
بتكفير قياده اوكرانيا فهم خنازير وفق
اعتقاده ليس ل ايمان ولا يفهمون الا لغه
القوه يقول
بحسب التقرير التالي يقترب مسلم السويد من
ان يصبح بدون مدارس اسلاميه لابنائهم
فالسلطات هناك اقفلت معظمها بتهمه نشر
التطرف لكنها ترفض تحديدا المواد والمناهج
التي تشتبه بها
اقفالوا المدارس الدينيه في السويد اقتصر
على الاسلاميه منها
ابنائهم بسبب الفقر مثلا في تلبيسوريا
وجامعات بناتهم في افغانستان بسبب رؤيه
خاصه لدى حركه طالبان لم نسمع عن مثيل لها
في العالم الاسلامي يا اخي الازهر يعلم
البنات ويخرج منهن المئات بل الالاف كل
عام حكومه حركه طالبان في افغانستان تقرر
حضره تعليم الجامعيه على الفتيات حتى شعر
اخر لا يبدو القرار معززا لجهود حركه
طالبان الساحيه لكسب اعتراف المانحين
الدوليين المحتملين في وقت تغرق فيه
البلاد في ازمه الانسانيه متفاقمه
في شخصين ادانتهما حاكم طيران بقتل فرد من
قوات التعبئه التابعه للحرس الثوري وذلك
خلال الاحتجاجات المستمره منذ اشهر مما
يرفع عدد المحتجين الذين اعدموا الى اربعه
حتى الان ولقد لقيه
الجديده تمديدا غربيا وامميه
تقرا صفحه من مذكرات الامير هاري ينشر
فيها اخبار العائله البريطانيه المالكه
وفضائها وان اخاه موليليم ضربه ذات مره
وقد ترك ذلك في نفسه اثرا كبيرا فتخالوا
نفسك امام كائن كيوت ومسالم لكنه يفاجئك
في صفحه اخرى بانه قاتل وبالجمله
ويتعاطى الكوكايين تحت عنوان سبيعي او
الاحتياطي للامير هاري الذي كشف في سطور
مذكراته عن قتله 25 من مسلحين حركه طالبان
في افغانستان
بالقطاع الشطرنج ازيلها من على اللون
مجرد قطاع الشطرنج اولئك الذين قتلتهم ليس
قطعه شطرنج بل اناس كان لديهم عائلات
انتظر عودتهم وتتوالى فصول الاعترافات
وفتح الاسرار من المشاجرات الى القتل
فتعاطى الكوكايين
و الرئيس البرازيلي السابق الذي خسر
الانتخابات مؤخرا لم يخيب ظن ملقبيه بترمب
البرازيل فعلى خطط ترامب قاطع مراسم تنصيب
سلفه ثم هزم انصارهم مقر الكونجرس في عمل
تخريبي رفضا لرئاسه الرئيس الفائز
بالانتخابات لويس اناثي سيلفا تدخل للشرطه
مبنى الكونجرس بعد ما اقتحمه مؤيدون
للرئيس السابق جرير بول سونارو الى جانب
القصر الرئاسي وساحه المحكمه الفدراليه
العليا في العاصمه برازيليه يحتجون على
تولي الرئيس لولا دا سيلفا السلطه جاهز
كما ماتكم فهناك من يعيدكم بحجر جديد
اسموه متحوره يوم القيامه لسرعه انتشاره
لكن منظمه الصحه العالميه تتخوف من ان
يصبح
متحوره جهنم متحور يوم القيامه اسم
الفزع اليس كذلك لكن التسميه جاءت من بعض
العلماء بسبب سرعه انتشاره رغم ان اعراضه
واصابته للجهاز التنفسي اقل مقارنه
بالمتحورات الاخرى غير ان اكثر ما يخيف
منظمه الصحه العالميه هو احتمال ان يكون
المتحول الجديد بوابه لمتحورات اخرى اكثر
خطوره بيروت
فهل تصبح باريس بيروت الغرب الشباب بفرنسا
بلشوا يخرجوا على الحطب صناعه الخبز على
الحطب لعلها تكون الحل الاخير في ظل ما
تعرفه فرنسا من ارتفاع كبير في اسعار
الطاقه
فرانك صاحب هذا المخبز الواقع في بلده
شالون بغرب فرنسا لم يكن يتوقع ما الت
اليه الاوضاع في بلاده وكيف اصبح الحطب
رغم ارتفاع يساره اقل كلفه من الكهرباء
اخيرا لقطات نادره وثقتها عدسات الصحفيين
والهواه تظهر مناطق مكه المكرمه وهي تخلع
لونها الرمليه الذهبي لتترشح بنبات اخضر
سندسي خرج بعد تدفق مياه الامطار بغزاره
على مدى ايام حيث اصبحت جبال مكه المكرمه
مكسوه بالعشب الاخضر للمره الاولى ربما
تاريخيا منذ فتره طويله بعد الامطار التي
شهدتها المنطقه خلال الفتره الماضيه
[موسيقى]
ختاما تقول حكايه تخلط بين الواقع والخيال
استيقظت مدينه ذات يوم على انتشار الكلاب
باعداد كبيره جدا في ساحتها وشوارعها وهي
تنبح بشكل هستيري لم يكن امام البلديه من
فكره الا ان تخلي المدينه من اهلها ريثما
تجد الحكومه حلا لهذه الازمه وبعد ساعات
على الرحيل سكان المدينه عنها ضربها زلزال
عنيف لم يبقي فيها حجرا على حجر
والخلاصه لا تبتئس ان هاجمتك الكلاب فان
بعضا نباح يقودك احيانا الى الطريق الصحيح
الى اللقاء
هو غلب كلام الناس ما عدل احساس
والناس تتفاوت دعاثير جبال
والكل باخلاقه مع الناس القاس
[موسيقى]